jetzt hier mit imaginären Freund
klatschen genau Mama
[Musik]
Freund klatschen 1 2 3 hallo 1 2 3 hallo
zusammen heute gibt es eine Hühnersuppe
test test
heute gibt es eine Hühnersuppe auf die
schnelle Art nicht aus dem ganzen
Hähnchen sondern ich habe Hühnerbrust
mit mit Haut und auch mit Fett das ist
immer auch Geschmacksträger und achte
darauf dass sie einen gutes Hühnchen
verwendet also Bioqualität weil wir
verwenden jetzt schon nicht den Knochen
daher generell immer auf gute Qualität
achten so das gebe ich jetzt hier einmal
in kochendes Wasser da kommt Salz und
Pfeffer dazu und die ganz genauen
Mengenangaben stehen wie immer unten in
der Infobox Infobox Salz und Pfeffer ich
Pfeffer du Salz
Teamarbeit ja und das ganze einfach nur
so lange kochen bis das Hähnchen gar ist
es dauert nicht lange dadurch dass es
auch nicht so ein dickes Stück ist
dauert das vielleicht nur so 8 bis 10
Minuten
ich bin fertig so und haben sie gerade
Suppengrün besorgt dann kann der Stelle
als reicht genau danke für Suppengrün
besorgen Suppengrün sind immer
abgepackte 500 g Päckchen da ist
Knollensellerie mit drin Lauch Möhren
Petersilie und die drei hübschen hier
werden wir jetzt fein schnippelnd
mit
dazugeben das sind Nudeln die kommt
später noch mit rein also Lorbeerblätter
einfach noch hier mit dazugeben und dann
kümmern wir uns um das Gemüse
[Musik]
es ist cool das ist beidseitig das nennt
man auch Produktentwicklung des Todes
war früher hat meine Mutter dass meine
gegeben für Kartoffeln und sowas ich
konnte das nicht an die Methode
entwickelt es geht zu drückst den Finger
drauf
eine Hühnersuppe und brauchen wir hier
aber 10 Jahre ich habe sogar noch einen
Schäler irgendwo
[Musik]
das nenne ich mal Teamwork oh soll ich
den wellenschneider benutzen das kann
man jetzt benutzen das kann man auch
eine Suppe tun ja nachhaltig aber lieber
nicht ja pass auf okay haben sie du
machst jetzt die du schneidest jetzt die
Möhrchen
du machst die Möhrchen bitte nein nein
bitte bitte halbieren erstmal das ganze
Ding halbieren und dann in so Halbkreise
schneiden ja wenn du Messer nimmst hast
du das Wellenmuster nicht
motiviert du bist was ist los mit dir so
auf jeden Fall sollte das Gemüse sehr
sehr klein einfach von angenehmes
Mundgefühl sehr klein geschnitten
ja
achtung bei Lauch und Porree ist immer
sehr viel Schmutz noch mit drin also ich
habe zwar gerade oberflächlich sauber
gemacht aber wenn es halbiert einfach
noch mal zwischen die Blätter geben und
noch mal richtig sauber machen
[Musik]
ich bin ja voller Anfänger
so gerade für Kinder wenn du dich
einfach so so halt die Klappe mach
einfach weißt du diese Aufgabe damit
[Musik]
aber genau das ist auch ein Anfänger
Kindermesser weil das ja nicht scharf
ist
ja beschäftigt jetzt kommt das Hähnchen
einmal raus das ist schön gar und das
wird gleich einfach zerrupft und wieder
reingegeben und jetzt muss noch das
Gemüse rein das muss ja gar werden und
ich gebe Nudeln mit dazu ja weil die
meisten Arbeit abgenommen hast ja
einfach rein
ich finde so süß gerade
öfter mal machen
bei den Nudeln also wenn ihr überhaupt
welche möchtet ich finde das gehört halt
irgendwie mal dazu es ist ja auch noch
mal zusätzlich sättigen einfach Nudeln
nehmen die nicht ganz so groß sind ihr
könntet jetzt auch Fadennudeln nehmen
die hat jetzt gerade auch hier aber ich
wollte einfach mal so also die sind
jetzt nur so halb so groß das sind das
Muschelnudeln
oder irgendwie sowas wenn wir eigentlich
auch eine Italienerin sitzen lacht
gerade ein bisschen aber ich hoffe es
hat richtig ausgesprochen
so auf jeden Fall kommen jetzt noch mit
rein und werden da jetzt gar gekocht das
dauert ja auch noch ein paar Minuten in
der Zwischenzeit werde ich hier das
Hähnchen zerrupfen das kommt am Ende
auch noch mit dazu und mit Salz und
Pfeffer schmecken natürlich braucht ihr
keine Gemüsebrühe denn das ist ja die
Gemüsebrühe und ein bisschen Wasser
nachgießen und dann ist es auch schon
fertig ey das ist live kochen das waren
jetzt 15 Minuten oder so also als Paar
ist es voll schön das ist romantisch und
so
[Musik]
was haben wir denn hier lecker Essen so
richtig hier gerade für Instagram was
aufgenommen habe da ich jetzt essen ja
selbst gekocht
eigentlich fast gar nichts mehr
reingetan bis ihr noch mal abgeschmeckt
hier braucht man dann wirklich nur Salz
und Pfeffer es gibt viele die machen
noch mal Gemüsebrühe rein braucht ihr
eigentlich nicht oder so gute
Nudeln haben sie meinte Fadennudeln
werden besser geworden
in dem Fall mit größeren Nudeln
aber warum eigentlich warum immer wenn
man krank ist finde mit Brot weil das
die Suppe hat sehr viel Vitamine ja das
Gemüse drin gutes Huhn gute Fette
Magnesium Eisen Kalzium und sowas das
ganze stimmt aber ich denke mal
gesund ihr habt noch mal die Zufuhr von
Flüssigkeit perfekt
und wir haben wirklich nur ich glaube 15
Minuten gebraucht wenn man schnibbelt
parallel und es geht einfach super
schnell also macht es unbedingt nach und
hinterlasst meinem Kanal kostenloses Abo
wenn ihr das nicht schon längst getan
habt und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten Rezept tschüss
[Musik]